Minnesota Democrat Amy Klobuchar was one
of the more than 40 senators who
questioned the Facebook CEO yesterday
she's with us from Capitol Hill
senator good morning good to see you
thanks so much for joining us Nora okay
we've heard lots of apologies from
Facebook and Zuckerberg have you seen
any real action taken by them they are
starting to make some changes now and at
the hearing you know he withstood this
for our grilling and he has more today
but I think the key is that this is
really not an end but a beginning what
are they really going to do on their
site is it going to be easy for you as a
user to be able to go in there and just
click that you want to keep your data
private are you gonna have to go to 30
spots on the site that's the first thing
secondly if there's a breach we want to
be able to know about it if you're one
of their users within you know I
suggested to him 72 hours so they are
making those changes as well as they've
agreed to comply with the bill that I
put forth with Senator McCain and Warner
that's the honest ads Act I've been on
your show discussing it in the past and
they're gonna start putting out all
their ads that they get political ads
post them with disclaimers that's a
major change but all of this we got to
see what happens and if they actually do
all but do you buy that when you hear
the CEO of Facebook still claim that
they're just a technology company that
they're not a media company I don't buy
that at all I think that they are a
media company they make tons of money
billions of dollars in ads just like you
run ads on your commercial breaks just
like radio shows run ads they are a
media company and that is why I believe
when you listen to Democrats and
Republicans at the hearing we are going
to put forward I'm working on a bill
today that I'm going to introduce
bipartisan a number of people are going
to be putting forward bills to start
putting rules of the road in place
because you just can't at Facebook doing
one thing you want to have all of them
having some privacy controls as well as
breach notifications and other ways a
bill of rights for users of these social
media company platforms so the question
is the Facebook can do a specific number
of things and that might please some
people but then there's the mindset
which based on all these apologies it
looks like it's
asked forgiveness and not permission if
that mindset doesn't change is anything
really going to change and do you think
it is possible to change that mindset I
think that the FTC may change that
mindset as you know they reached a
consent decree with Facebook back in
2011 and are now looking at some of the
biggest number of fines that we've ever
seen because in my mind they violated
the promises that they made and that's
according to FTC experts as well so that
kind of money talks and then you also
have the fact that their stock went down
that they've lost trust at which he has
admitted with the public and all of
those reasons means if it's not just a
moral reason it's a money reason that
you want to see changes from this
company if you've never seen them before
these media companies start saying well
maybe we need some rules because by the
way if we don't do it on the federal
level and we better the states are
starting to do it so they're going to
get a patchwork of laws if they don't
start supporting some reasonable
regulation on the federal level well
yesterday and today Facebook was on the
hot seat and you've said you'd like to
see the CEOs of Twitter and Google also
come and testify why is that important
to you and why did so many senators need
to question Mark Zuckerberg yesterday
that's a great question you think 43
senators is too many
mr. tad yes yes exactly I did note that
some of them were teasing them that some
of them may not have understood this
there's only a few of them that have
flip phones I want to start with that
okay um but you know I think that we had
we combined the Commerce Committee and
the Judiciary Committee instead of
having them do two appearances and I
think there are a lot of good questions
asked especially about the Russian
investigation and I also think the other
companies have to come forward Twitter
just announced yesterday they're
supporting my bill with Senator McCain
and Warner to put forward the same rules
of the road for social media companies
that you have for traditional media
companies when it comes to political ads
that's a big deal and now we're pushing
for Google to get on board as well all
right senator cloaks are always good to
have you thank you so much angry I'm
just great to be on thank you